سنبدا صباحنا معكم اليوم بمكالمه
بالمعرفه والاخبار ولكن سنحرص عادل ان
تكون وجيزه
وقصيره لانه يبدو صحيا مزيد من الدقائق
يعني طبعا على الهاتف يعني خطر اكبر على
صحتك اذا كنت ممن يتحدثون لفترات طويله
على الهاتف عليك الانتباه لموضوع هذه
الفقره تحديدا دراسه جديده وجدت ان
المكالمه الهاتفيه لمده 30 دقيقه واكثر في
الاسبوع ترتبط بزياده خطر الاصابه بارتفاع
ضغط الدم والقلب مضبوط ووفقا للورقه
البحثيه المنشوره في مجله يعرفي هارت
فان اولئك الذين يتصلون هاتفيا بشكل منتظم
ويقضون ساعه على الهاتف يوميا هم الاكثر
عرضه للاصابه بهذه الحالات المشاركون في
البحث الصادر من الصين اكدوا على اهميه
ابقاء مكالمات الهاتف المحمول عند الحد
الادنى للحفاظ على صحه القلب المزيد من
النتائج والتفاصيل في الشرح التالي مع
علاء سرحان علاء
شكرا عادل وراويه ما يقارب من ثلاثه ارباع
سكان العالم في سن العاشره وما فوق
يمتلكون هاتفا محمولا حسب التقديرات يعاني
ما يقارب من مليار وثلاث مئه مليون بالغ
من الذين تتراوح اعمارهم بين ثلاثين لتسعه
وسبعين عاما في جميع انحاء العالم من
ارتفاع ضغط الدم وبما ان الهواتف المحموله
تصدر مستويات منخفضه من طاقه الترددات
الراديويه لهذا ربطتها دراسات بارتفاع ضغط
الدم بعد التعرض لها لفتره قصيره على مدار
12 عاما حلل فريق بحثي صيني بيانات اكثر
من 200 الف بالغ تتراوح اعمارهم بين 37
و73 عاما ولا يعانون من ارتفاع ضغط الدم
مع اسئله تتضمن ما اذا كانوا يستخدمون
مكبره صوت او جهاز بلوتوث من دون استخدام
اليدين حول
ساعات الاستخدام والتاريخ العائلي المرضي
كل هذه الاسئله في النهايه اكتشفوا ان
الاشخاص الذين يقضون اكثر من 6 ساعات على
الهاتف اسبوعيا لديهم خطر ارتفاع ضغط الدم
بنسبه 25% مقارنه باولئك الذين يقضون اقل
من خمس دقائق فقط في اجراء او استقبال
المكالمات الهاتفيه
[موسيقى]
سالنا الناس في الاردن كم من الوقت
تستهلكه على المكالمه الهاتفيه ماذا اجابه
[موسيقى]
ما بتعدوا دقيقه دقيقتين يعني مكالمه
سريعه بس ايام الخطوبه كان الواحد يطول
يعني كان في سبب انه الواحد يطول يسهر مع
خطيبته وهيك لا تتجاوز دقيقه تقريبا مع
تطور السوشيال ميديا وسائل الاتصال كله
صارت مسجات بين الواتساب وايميل دقيقتين
لخمس دقائق بس اكثر من هيك لا ما بكثره
بالمكالمه
[موسيقى]
هل من دقيقه لانه ما الي خلق اقعد على
التليفون مو كتير لانه خلص الواحد صار
يعني في برامج تبعون الاتصال اللي على
الانترنت بخصوص الواحد بصير يقضي وقت اكثر
عليهم حسب الشخص هلا في ناس مستعده أضل
معهم يوم كامل على التلفون ما عندي مشكله
في اشخاص ما بتحملهم ثاني
[موسيقى]
دكتور احمد السكري مستشار امراض القلب
التداخليه اهلا بك دكتور احمد معنا في
صباح العربيه دكتور احمد خلينا نبدا
بالموضوع على طول كيف بتاثر المكالمات
الهاتفيه على ضغط الدم وعلى صحه القلب هلا
عم نحكي عن ترددات الموجات الصوتيه او
للاشعاعات من التلفونات المحموله هل كمان
الفيديو كول لها نفس التاثير واللي عم
نحكي بس على ما هو مسموع فقط مكالمه صوتيه
بصي اول حاجه الفكره كلها ان احنا لو
تكلمنا على اضرار الموبايل لحد دلوقتي لم
يثبت بحث علمي واحد على مدى 30 سنه ان في
علاقه مباشره
ما بين الموبايل وصحه الانسان لم يثبت
يعني مثلا تابعوا الاثار الجانبيه على مدى
طويل على ماده 30 سنه وشافه عن عدد مثلا
الكانسر او السرطانات زادت في بعد استخدام
الموبايل لم يثبت فنفس عدد الاصابه
بالكانسر هي نفس عدد الاصابه ولذلك يتم
استبعاد الموبايل تدريجيا من الخطوره على
صحه الانسان البحث اللي اتعمل ده هو بحث
وحيد وهو بحث فقط وحيد هو بحث طبعا اتعمل
في مستشفى الصينيه دكتور كوكو خد البيانات
الموجوده في بعض المرضى الموجودين في
بريطانيا حوالي اكتر من 200 الف مريض
وتابعهم على ماده 12 سنه وربط عدد
المكالمات
وصحه وضغط الدم وجد ان بعض الناس مثلا
اللي بتستخدم الموبايل بيزيد نسبه الاصابه
بالضغط بنسبه 7% بالمقارنه الناس اللي ما
بتستخدمش الموبايل طب الناس اللي بتستخدم
الموبايل وجد الناس اللي بتتكلم اكتر من
30 دقيقه في الاسبوع خلاص بمقارنه بالناس
اللي بتتكلم اقل من 30 دقيقه في الاسبوع
نسبه الاصابه حوالي 12% 30 دقيقه في
الاسبوع ده رقم صعب جدا ده معناه ان في
اليوم اربع دقايق و 17 سنه وكنا غير منطقي
اطلاقا هل هذا مرتبط دكتور بانه لما تمارس
الرياضه على حسب الفئه العمريه يجب ان
يكون ضغط القلب لا يتجاوز حد معينات اكثر
من 140 او الى الى انا ما عندي هذا الرقم
لكن هل الانفعالات اللي يمر فيها الانسان
بهذه المكالمه الهاتفيه هي التي قد تسبب
لها هذه الامر انت جبت مربط الفرس هل في
علاقه مباشره بصحه الانسان والموبايل لا
توجد علاقه مباشره حتى الان هل توجد علاقه
غير مباشره او توجد يعني وجدوا نسبه
الوفيات زادت بعد استخدام الموبايل نتيجه
حوادث الطرق
لاي انسان ده يعتبر افساد للسلاب النفسي
لاي حد يعني انت معك الموبايل 24 ساعه اي
شخص ممكن يتواصل معك في اي لحظه في ال 24
ساعه ده اسمه افساد السلام النفسي ده
معناه ان الستريس ليفل عندك بيزيد او
التوتر
الهاتف النقال هو وسيله للاتصال والاتصال
مع الاخرين هو شيء مهم للصحه
يعني اتصال انا محتاج طلب معين الطلب ده
بياخذ في المكالمه دي او دقيقتين لكن هو
دلوقتي مش وسيله الاتصال هو وسيله
للمقابلات يعني الاول الناس كانت بتتقابل
بره ممكن يتقابلوا ساعه دلوقتي ممكن
يتكلموا ساعه 2/3
تساهل ان ده عمل بعد اجتماعي بين الناس
هذا غير غير الواتساب بالنسبه للامهات
المتقاعدات
خلينا خلينا نتكلم بانه اليوم هل احنا
كشعب
بالمجتمع العربي احنا بنحب الكلام هل هذا
لا ينطبق علينا ام انه هو جزء يعني من
الممكن انه يكون مؤثر انت بتحب الكلام انت
هتستغرب ان مش المجتمع العربي هو اللي
بيحب الكلام انت لو رحت شاري اسيا اكثر
مننا في الكلام عن الموبايلات لو رحت
اوروبا لو رحت امريكا ونفس الاستخدام ونفس
عدد تقريبا ساعات اليوم ودراسه اللي
اتعملت دي اتعملت في بريطانيا ما اتعملتش
هنا خلاص بس انا عاوز اقول حقيقه على
الموبايل تاني الموبايل بيطلع حاجه اسمها
ترددات منخفضه كهرومغناطيسيه من حوالي 450
ل 2700 ميجا واط دي جرعه بسيطه غير مؤثره
لكن برضو الموبايل بيطلع طاقه الطاقه دي
لا تزيد عن الاتنين حراره بحس الواحد
بيسخن انا لما احط الموبايل على الجلد
حراره الموبايل ممكن تنتقل للمخ تنتقل
للاعضاء بس برضه لحد دلوقتي لا يوجد بحث
علمي هل ده يؤثر على المدى الطويل ام لا
يوجد بحث
هل بناء على هذه الدراسه لانهم بيحبوا
الحكي اكثر
وبيقضوا وقت اطول على التليفون هل هن اكثر
عرضه طبعا في الموضوع والمحبين طبعا
العشاق لا اسمها عبد الحليم بس انا اقول
لك على حاجه النساء رغم ان هم بيستخدموا
الموبايل قطر عشان كده الحاجه دي ضد
الدراسه نفس اول بحث النساء رغم ان هم
اكثر استخدام الموبايل اقل عرضه للضغط
بيرفعوا ضغطنا احنا لا لا
اخرى للتنفيس فبالتالي بيعبروا عن نفسهم
مشاعرهم اكثر من الرجال استخدام الموبايل
للاستخدام المهم فقط حاول استخدم السماعات
استخدام السماعات السلكيه بتقلل نسبه
انتقال الحراره بنسبه 10% عشان
البلوتوث بيقلل الانتقال الحراره بنسبه
اقل بنسبه 100% 100 مره فدي حاجه مهمه
دكتور احمد السكري استشاري امراض القلب
التداخليه شكرا جزيلا لك وسلامه قلوب
الناس كلها صباح الفل صباح
[موسيقى]
الفل
انا لما باجي اتكلم في الموبايل بتاعي
يعني بص حاجات على حسب الموضوع اللي بتكلم
فيه ولما بتكون عندي شغل يعني على حسب بقى
الموضوع بيطول بلفلف كده يعني مثلا ممكن
اه ممكن بقى زمان ده قبل الجواز الكلام ده
كله ساعه ساعتين براحتنا يعني مش اكثر من
دقيقتين ثلاثه لكن الرغي ده احنا بالرغم
ان انت طبيعتنا نحب الرغي دودو دودو ابص
الاقي الست من دول ماسكه التليفون وقعدت
الساعه 3:00 طبقتي ايه عملتي ايه ساعات
اوقات مكالماتي ممكن غصب عني الطول مني
شويه حسب فكره الموضوع يعني المكالمات
العائليه مثلا ممكن يوم ما اقول ان انا
خمس دقائق مثلا مكالمات الشغل برده نفس
الرنج تقريبا واحد صاحبك مثلا يكلمك
ثواني بالضبط ايوه انت فين انا جيت خلاص
وكان واحده صاحبتك طبعا تختلف ازيك الاول
عامله ايه بتعملي ايه النهارده كده بس
[موسيقى]
بعطي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات